to say She-Hulk was meta as a bit of an
understatement in a show that was mostly
Easter eggs these are the ones you
probably missed the second episode of
She-Hulk attorney at law sees Jennifer
unceremoniously fired after the
courtroom fight with Titania disrupts
her trial and turns her into a media
sensation after a disappointing and
humiliating job search Jennifer is
surprised when her former courtroom
rival Holden Holloway personally hires
her for the new superhuman law division
at his firm glknh glknh stands for
Goodman Lieber kurzburg and Holloway
while Holloway is already present in the
series as a recurring supporting
character the names of the firm's other
three co-founders have deep ties to the
Golden Age of Marvel Martin Goodman was
the original publisher of timely Comics
which later became known as Marvel and
the first ever issue of Marvel Comics in
1939. Libra and kurtzberg are the birth
names of Stan Lee and Jack Kirby who
under their more famous pen names
co-created the Fantastic Four the X-Men
Black Panther and the Incredible Hulk
among others first appearing in dance
slots and Juan babill's She-Hulk number
one in 2004 glknh is a significant part
of she-hulk's publishing history and the
perfect firm to handle the increasingly
offbeat world of superhuman law the MCU
20th century Fox's X-Men film series was
the first major superhero franchise of
the 21st century changing the trajectory
of cinematic Blockbusters forever the
X-Men Saga feature Hugh Jackman in the
iconic role of Wolverine a mutant
superhero sporting a healing factor six
adamantium claws and a Berserker rage
though Wolverine is one of Marvel's most
popular Heroes the fox X-Men films were
not produced by Marvel Studios meaning
they exist outside the MCU when Disney
acquired 20th Century Fox in 2019 fans
began to speculate about how and when
the Marvel Cinematic Universe would
finally incorporate the X-Men a
speculation increased in 2022 after Ms
Marvel revealed Kamala Khan to be the
first confirmed mutant in the MCU
Kamala there's something different
in your jeans
like
[Music]
like a mutation on the heels of that
bombshell the latest Easter egg hinting
at the presence of mutants in the MCU is
on she-hulk's computer in episode 2 of
her Disney Plus show blank and you'll
miss an internet headline wedged between
an ad for Iron Man themed sneakers and
an article about the giant Celestial
sticking out of the ocean man fights
with metal claws and Barbara and Marvel
Comics metal claws and bar brawls
usually point to one man and the 2000
X-Men film even features Wolverine
unleashing his claws on Rowdy bar
patrons in an early scene She-Hulk is a
fitting spot for Wolverine's first
mention in the MCU he made his debut in
1974's Incredible Hulk number 181. after
an awkward family dinner in episode 2
Jennifer has a much needed drink at
legalese a bar frequented by her fellow
lawyers an episode of the 1990s comedy
drama series Ally McBeal plays on the
television about the bar with Calista
Flockhart as the show's namesake briefly
appearing on screen premiering on Fox in
1997 Ally McBeal was a popular series
about a boston-based lawyer and her
complicated personal and professional
life the show balanced courtroom drama
with colorful fantasy sequences
including a famous scene where Ali can't
stop seeing a CGI baby a manifestation
of her ticking biological clock she
hoped director Kat koiro has spoken a
variety about her show sharing a Vibe
with Ally McBeal noting that it played
with the law firm genre and turned it on
its head and made it very feminine Ally
McBeal actually has another connection
to the MCU in the fourth season Robert
Downey Jr joined the cast as Ali's love
interest Larry Paul he would go on to
win a Golden Globe for his performance
before being written off the show since
Ally McBeal exists in the MCU there must
be an actor in that Universe with an
uncanny resemblance to Tony Stark
2022's Thor love and thunder
reintroduces audiences to new Asgard the
city in Norway that has become a second
home for surviving asgardians and a
colorful tourist spot for residents of
the MCU but what do the resettled
asgardians do for fun if they aren't
part of a memorable acting troupe or
going on Cosmic adventures with Thor and
Valkyrie She-Hulk episode 3 gives us the
answer in Runa the mischievous light elf
and is placed as guardian who's being
sued by Jennifer's obnoxious former
co-worker Dennis Bukowski light elves
reside in Alpine one of the nine Realms
Thor mentions Alpine by name in his
original 2011 film you what realm is
this that's fine dornheim New Mexico but
neither the land nor its residents and
actually appeared on screen until
She-Hulk attorney at law a normal amount
of Rage wastes no time in explaining how
Jennifer Walters gained superpowers in
the MCU showing audiences the dramatic
car crash that led to Jennifer
cross-contaminating her blood with
Bruce's in episode 3 Jennifer exits the
Maximum Security Prison housing Tim
Rossi meal Blonsky and is surrounded by
reporters covering blonsky's temporary
Escape one journalist asks a very
specific and inaccurate question is
there any truth to the rumors you got
your powers from a mafia had gone wrong
this line is a direct nod to she-hulk's
very different origin story in the
Savage She-Hulk number one in which her
blood transfusion happens under
different circumstances in the comic
book Jennifer and Bruce reunite after
many years during Jennifer's ongoing
investigation into the Crime Boss named
Trask and Bruce is a witness when
trask's Hitman shoot Jennifer in the
back thinking on his feet Bruce gives
her the transfusion to save her life and
Jennifer becomes She-Hulk for the first
time when trask's men break into her
hospital room to finish the job
on top of obviously famous clients like
Megan the stallion Jennifer's day job
also puts the cases craft be Sewell and
Lee B burn on her to-do list name
dropping four comic book creators who
have contributed to she-hulk's Mighty
Marvel Mythos over the years writer
David Anthony craft and all but a single
issue of Jennifer's first solo series
The Savage She-Hulk from 1980 to 82.
Meanwhile Charles Sewell a comic book
author and real life attorney wrote a
2014-2015 She-Hulk series a legendary
Stan Lee co-created She-Hulk and wrote
the first issue of the Savage shield and
John Byrne is written and drawn multiple
books featuring She-Hulk including her
tenure on the Fantastic Four and several
issues in the
1989-1994 The Sensational She-Hulk
Series in fact he's the writer who first
had She-Hulk break the fourth wall with
Deadpool famously following suit so many
years later when clients like these it's
no wonder Jennifer is so busy they say
clothes make the man but what about
superheroes She-Hulk episode 5 mean
green and straight poured into these
jeans introduces Luke Jacobson a Los
Angeles Fashion Designer with a sharp
eye and sharper tongue for superhero
costumes working in a private studio for
his very exclusive clientele Luke agrees
to design new suits for She-Hulk only
after being assured that Bruce Banner's
cousin is a future Avenger herself by
the way we told him you're an Avenger
what the Marvel Universe has a few
famous fashion designers in its ranks
including Janet Van Dyne still Luke
Jacobson is one of the more obscure
Marvel characters to make the leap from
page to screen with only a handful of
comic appearances since his Creation in
1986 debuting in Dakota North number one
by Martha tomasses and Tony Sammons Luke
hires a glamorous globetrotting private
investigator for protection Dakota North
was canceled after only five issues but
has since become a cult series and it
ended with Luke developing a fashion
line inspired by the action heroine
She-Hulk episode 5 concludes with the
exciting reveal that Luke is the
designer of the yellow and red Daredevil
costume seen in promotional materials
and Marvel's Daredevil series x-con
armor Melvin Potter designed Matt
Murdoch's costume however in season
three Melvin was last seen being
arrested by the FBI which could explain
Daredevil's need for a new costume
designer every episode of She-Hulk
attorney at law finishes with the
credits rolling over courtroom sketch
inspired illustrations by Kagan MacLeod
these stylish and funny credit sequences
have a few images unique to the
episode's plot and episode 5 includes a
sketch with an up visual Easter eggs to
fill a walk-in closet that drawing in
question features Nikki and Pug's quest
for designer superhero clothing after
pug recruits Nikki to help him score a
limited edition pair of Iron Man 3
sneakers the Iron Man 3s were advertised
in episode 2 and during the end credits
to episode 5 puck finally shows them off
in front of his collection of superhero
themed sneakers MCU fans will quickly
recognize sneaker designs based on
familiar Heroes like Captain Marvel
Hawkeye Black Panther and Moon Knight
however pug also has sneakers for Heroes
scheduled to appear in the MCU like
winged shoes for Namor played by tinosh
Huerta on black panther wakanda forever
as well as orange Rocky sneakers
reminiscent of the thing who fans hope
to see in Marvel's 2025 Fantastic Four
film there's even a nod to the infamous
Green Goblin X-Men fans eager for any
and all signs of the mutants joining the
Marvel Cinematic King universe will also
be surprised to see shoes referencing
Deadpool Cyclops and cable three
characters featured in the fox X-Men
films that exist outside the MCU
chihok attorney at law episode 5 ends
with a cliffhanger teasing the much
anticipated arrival of Daredevil to the
show well The Man Without Fear doesn't
appear in episode 6 just gen features
the MCU debut of a classic superhero who
once LED his own Avengers team
unfortunately that team was the Great
Lakes Avengers Craig Hollis Alias Mr
Immortal is a new client for Mallory
book and Nikki Ramos at glknh true to
his name Mr Immortal cannot die though
he has faked his death several times to
escape his numerous marriages I do I die
but only for a little kind of die
created by John Byrne in the 1986 comic
West Coast Avengers number 46. Mr
Immortal is homo Supreme neither human
nor mutant but someone who has evolved
Beyond Death wanting to use his
superpowers for good he formed the Great
Lakes Avengers team with zela
superheroes doorman Big Bertha dinosaur
and flat man albeit without approval
from any other active Avengers teams
though Craig Hollis on She-Hulk is
flippant about his immortality in the
comics Mr Immortal hates outliving
everyone he loves in the conclusion of
2004's GLA miniseries the cosmic entity
death urge tells Hollis that his Destiny
is to be the last being alive at the end
of the universe so that he will learn
the grand secret that will reveal itself
at the end of all things Immortal Hulk
number 24 depicts a grim possible future
where Mr Immortal finally dies at the
hands of a possessed Bruce Banner
as Mallory and Nikki talk to Mr
immortal's Exes in just gen one mentions
that she learned the truth about her
husband's immortality when a video on
the website Intelligentsia showed him
regenerating after a car accident
Mallory remarks that the site is for
hateful man babies and later she and
Nikki make a dark Discovery when they
register for an account a Content
aggregator site Intelligentsia Jose
cancel She-Hulk page that posts
misogynistic memes and death threats
against Jennifer in the final moments of
the episode Intelligentsia member Hulk
King seems poised to make those threats
a reality the word Intelligentsia has an
ominous ring for long time Hulk fans it
was a name taken by a collective of evil
super Geniuses at first assembled and
followed the Hulk's Alpha number one in
2009 consisting of the leader Dr Doom
the Mad thinker and Modoc among other
villains the Intelligentsia sought to
gather lost Arcane knowledge such as
secrets from the Library of Alexandria
hidden in wakanda Atlantis and the
Eternal City of Olympia the
Intelligentsia would later be revealed
as the minds behind several major events
in the MCU such as the coming of the
beyonder and the creation of the Red
Hulk She-Hulk commits to a potent bit of
social satire by reimagining the
self-proclaimed group of Evil Geniuses
as a site for the internet's most
hateful trolls
She-Hulk attorney at law episode 7 The
Retreat introduces a Cavalcade of
colorful new characters pulled from some
of the most obscure back issues of
Marvel Comics but Emilio blonski's power
inhibitor goes on the fritz Jennifer
visits his secluded summer Twilight's
Retreat to be sure he's not violating
his parole as the Abomination there
Jennifer gets a rude surprise when the
Superhuman man bull damages her car and
forces She-Hulk to take the man bull by
the horns man bull was created as a
villain for another horn-headed Marvel
character first appearing in 1971's
Daredevil number 78 in the retreat man
bull tells She-Hulk that he was a weird
lab experiment which is true to his
comic book Origins William Torrens was a
career criminal working for an evil
scientist when he was injected with a
serum that mutated him into a rampaging
half-man half Bowl frequently in and out
of prison man bull has tussled with
Heroes like the Hulk Black Widow and
Spider-Woman over the years the 2005
comic Spider-Man Unlimited number 12
shows man bull trying to get a grip on
his anger issues and the villain's
Anonymous support group which appears to
have been unsuccessful while the man
Bowl on chiho carries a grudge against
al Aguila for looking like a matador in
the comics man bull actually teams up
with a fellow d-list villain named The
Matador El Aguila is Spanish for the
eagle is symbolized on his chest makes
his first appearance in episode 7.
unlike most of the new characters
introduced in episode 7 El Aguila is not
a super villain he's a self-described
swashbuckler in the vein of Robin Hood
and Zorro and before you make
assumptions no I am not a matador
Alejandro Montoya debuted in Powerman
and Iron Fist number 58 a mutant with
the power to channel bioelectricity
through his sword El Aguila became a
masked vigilante on the streets of New
York City targeting drug dealers and
slumlords and becoming a youth hero as
the heroes for hire Powerman and Iron
Fist were employed to bring El Aguila to
justice but after a crisis of conscious
they teamed up with him instead El
Aguila became a recurring character and
Power Man and Iron Fist but made few
appearances after that and he was
de-powered by Scarlet Witch during the
decimation event in the retreat to El
Aguila wields his bioelectric sword
though it's unclear if he's still a
mutant in the MCU whether he's a mutant
or not El Aguila is one of the most
surprising characters the MCU could have
ever introduced Jennifer meets porcupine
when she abruptly crashes Emile
blonski's super Bean support group
meeting outfitted head to toe in his
massive quilled costume porcupine shows
his face tip group for the first time in
a moment of vulnerability though they
are repulsed by the smell just leave the
suit on and until we can get it
dry cleaned in Marvel Comics there are
two characters who have worn the
porcupine armor the first to a scientist
Alexander Gentry who designed the suit
for the United States Army but used it
for his own nefarious purposes he first
appeared in 1963's Tales to astonish
number 48 battling Ant-Man and the WASP
the second porcupine Roger gokane
debuted in 2006's Daughters of the
Dragon number three in a redesigned suit
Roger later reformed and became the
nanny for spider-woman's baby son the
porcupine from the episode is remarkably
faithful to artist Don heck's original
design his name isn't revealed but he's
probably Alexander Gentry Gentry offered
to sell his suit to The Avengers in
exchange for helping Captain America
infiltrate the evil serpent Society only
to be fatally impaled on one of his own
quills he came back though and had an
encounter with She-Hulk in The
Sensational She-Hulk number 59 as a
character witness for a trial when the
fourth wall breaking shoehawk points out
that he's supposed to be deceased
porcupine realizes that she's right and
suddenly drops dead near the end of
episode 7 Jennifer leaves blonsky's
retreats in the tow truck that has
finally come to claim her damaged Prius
the truck company's slot Towing is sure
to bring in knowing smile to longtime
fans of Jennifer Walters and Marvel
Comics since it's named after She-Hulk
scribe dance slot a prolific writer Dan
slot is perhaps best known for the books
he has written for Marvel Comics which
include The Amazing Spider-Man the
Fantastic Four and She-Hulk slot's
tenure on She-Hulk which began with a 12
issue 2004 series and includes a run
from 2005 to 2007 serves as a major
inspiration for She-Hulk attorney at law
it was slot who introduced the idea of
Jennifer as a practicing lawyer for the
superhero community and he co-created
supporting characters Mallory book and
Augustus pug puglisi The Retreat pays
further tribute to the influential
Creator upon close inspection the name
tag on the tow truck driver's shirt
appears to read Daniel or Dan
want to be superhero and consummate rich
kid LeapFrog become she-hulk's client in
episode 8. after his Luke Jacobson
designed rocket boosters malfunction
during a mission the She-Hulk version of
LeapFrog is an amalgamation of two
semi-obscure amphibian themed Marvel
Comics characters LeapFrog and Frogman
the pair are actually father and son
Vincent and Eugene patilio with Vincent
debuting as the villainous LeapFrog and
Daredevil number 25 a small time
inventor and bank robber Vincent
eventually retired from his life of
crime to raise his family and Marvel
team-up number 121 his son Eugene
unearths his old costume and with a code
named Frogman helps Spider-Man and Human
Torch in their battle against Speed
Demon thus begins one of the most
unlikely superhero careers in Marvel
history Brandon Stanley plays Eugene
patilio and chihol though he now goes by
his father's code name LeapFrog while
the Eugene in the comics is a bumbling
but good-hearted hero in the show he is
a much more devious character he kidnaps
Luke Jacobson to make him a new super
suit with Daredevil and She-Hulk
crashing his Lily Pad Hideout to bring
him to Justice
episode 8 features a special guest
appearance by Charlie Cox reprising the
role of lawyer Matt Murdock AKA
Daredevil Fancy Remember Murdoch from
the 2015 Daredevil TV series may be
surprised to see him sporting a dramatic
new red and yellow costume after
unmasking Matt Jennifer remarks which is
very daring to use ketchup and mustard
as your color Escape for the costume's
unusual colors have deep significance to
Matt Murdoch's personal history
stretching back to his very first
appearance in 1964's Daredevil number
one created by Stan Lee and Bill Everett
Daredevil wore a flashy yellow and red
suit for the first six issues of a
series before artist Wallace wood
redesigned the costume in Daredevil
number seven giving the crime fighter
the distinctive all red Loki is best
known for today the 2001 mini-series
Daredevil Yellow by Tim sale and Jeff
Loeb delved into Matt's Origins
explaining that his first suit was sewed
together from the yellow and red boxing
robe that belonged to his father battle
and Jack Murdoch flashbacks in the
Daredevil season 1 episode cut man
feature Jack Murdock wearing those
colors as a nod to the comic Jennifer
breaks the fourth wall near the end of
episode 8 wondering why it's still
continuing after her romantic night with
Daredevil she predicts that there will
be a big twist leading up to the season
finale wondering is it the kind of twist
that's like oh there's another Hulk but
this one's red Bruce Banner's Hulk has
been a few different shades over the
decades but there was a different Red
Hulk in the comics debuting in 2008's
Hulk number one the identity of the Red
Hulk was initially a mystery he kept his
intelligence when he transformed making
him a formidable Foe for the Hulk is
eventually revealed to be General
Thaddeus Thunderbolt Ross transformed by
the Intelligentsia Think Tank the comics
version of The Group shares little more
than a name with the version in She-Hulk
William Hurt played Thunderbolt Ross in
the MCU though his version of Ross never
became Red Hulk on screen he told the
Wall Street Journal in 2015 that he
would be willing to take a shot at the
Crimson Titan sadly Hurt died in 2022 so
barring a recasting of Thunderbolt Ross
the odds of seeing a red Hulk in the MCU
have diminished talking to the audience
about a different possible Late episode
twist Jennifer asks or like I'm getting
fridged the word fridge refers to an
Infamous story that led to a catch-all
term for the mistreatment of women in
comic books in 1994 DC Comics published
Green Lantern number 54 in which the
super villain Major Force attacks Green
Lantern's girlfriend Alex DeWitt and
kills her stuff in her corpse in a
refrigerator for Green Lantern to find
later comic book writer Gail Simone
recognized a trend in which female
characters and superhero comics tended
to be maimed killed or de-powered at a
disproportionate rate and often only to
further a male Hero's storyline she
coined the term fridging to describe
this phenomenon composing a list of
fridged female characters the women in
refrigerators website launched in 1999
continuing the conversation in the comic
book community and sharing responses
from creators that are still available
to read Simone wrote it occurred to me
that it's not that healthy to be a
female character in comics if he
demolish most of the characters girls
like then girls won't read Comics that's
it Jennifer Walters Esquire lawyer
millennial
with those words the She-Hulk attorney
at law season finally pays homage to the
very first Hulk live action series the
episode opens with a shot by shot
Recreation of the opening credits for
the 1978 CBS series The Incredible Hulk
the stylized dream sequence intercuts
new footage was scenes from the 1978
show and replaces Incredible Hulk actor
Bill Bixby with Tatiana maslani the
Pitch Perfect Recreation which includes
bell bottoms boxy computer Terminals and
an omniscient narrator also swaps out
the CGI She-Hulk with a performer in
green makeup a tip of the hat to the
iconic blue Ferrigno best of all
Jennifer says the original Show's
Immortal catchphrase don't make me angry
you wouldn't like me when I'm angry
following in the footsteps of Ms Marvel
and Moon Knight the She-Hulk series
features hidden QR codes in every
episode which viewers can scan at home
to access a free digital Marvel comic
book relevant to the episode and the
pilots a QR code can be seen on the wall
of the bar Jennifer stumbles into after
her accident leading viewers to her
first appearance in 1980s Savage
She-Hulk number one in episode 2 a QR
code on Jennifer's laptop screen leads
to 2004's She-Hulk number one which
introduces the GLK and H firm episode 3
has a code below the u-screen player for
Savage She-Hulk number two which
features lawyer Dennis Bukowski the
fourth code on Jennifer's dating profile
is good for West Coast Avengers annual
number four or She-Hulk is nearly made
the Bride of the evil God set episode 5
features a QR code in the Boba Tea shop
for 2004 She-Hulk number 10 Titania's
origin story a QR code on the crushed
car in episode 6 leads to 1989's West
Coast Avengers number 46 Mr Immortals
comic debut the food truck in episode 7
has a QR code for 1963's Tales to
astonish number 48 featuring guest star
porcupine in episode 8 to sign in front
of leapfrog's Lily Pad Hideout leads to
a She-Hulk Daredevil team up in 2014's
She-Hulk number nine finally the code on
the writer's room door and the season
finale leads to 1993's Sensational
She-Hulk number 50 where Jennifer breaks
the fourth wall to argue with her
creative team
Hulk has been breaking the fourth wall
since the first episode but in the
season finale she smashes it to Pieces
dissatisfied with the direction of the
episode and the four-way fight scene
between Todd Hulk Abomination Titania
and Bruce Jennifer stops the episode
cold bringing up the Disney plus menu
screen she kicks her way into the
docu-series Marvel Studios assemble
effectively entering the real world in a
sequence packed with behind the scenes
production art toys comics and clips
from previous MCU projects She-Hulk
enters Marvel Studios and interrogates
her writer's room complete with
fictionalized versions of showrunner
Jessica gal and writer Zep Wells hearing
that her story has been decided by Kevin
She-Hulk fights her way to the head of
Marvel Studios instead of meeting Marvel
Studios president Kevin feige she meets
Kevin a giant AI brain with an advanced
entertainment algorithm that appears to
be wearing a baseball cap it stands for
knowledge enhance visual entertain
activity Nexus after Kevin asked
She-Hulk to transform back into Jennifer
off-screen budget restraints Jennifer
gives a closing argument in favor of an
ending not beholden to the unwritten
rule rules of the superhero genre this
type of meta humor was heavily employed
in John Byrne's Sensational She-Hulk run
in issue number 37 she tears through
blank pages berating burn for failing to
provide a decent ending here Jennifer
wins over Kevin and gets a new ending
Jennifer's jolly green cousin Bruce
Banner listed a smug Hulk on her phone
has been missing in action since the
series second episode he was last seen
on a spaceship preparing to take care of
some important business on the planet's
car in episode 9 Bruce returns to earth
and introduces his family to his happy
alien half-hulk son scar played by will
dustner scar was likely conceived as a
car sometime between the events of
Avengers Age of Ultron and Thor Ragnarok
Oscar's mother is not mentioned in
she-hole in the comics she's the warrior
Kyra the old strong in the planet Hulk
storyline Hulk fell in love with Kyra
who later died in an explosion the
Kyra's son survived making his debut in
2007's World War Hulk number five having
rapidly aged to adulthood due to his
alien hybrid DNA scar is a formidable
fighter with enhanced strength and
stamina of befitting the whole he comes
the Earth seeking revenge on his father
though the two eventually reconcile
while talking to cinema Bland about the
sicarian spaceship in episode 1 She-Hulk
director Kat Coro teased that it also
lends itself to Future projects with the
appearance of Scar viewers have a better
idea of what those projects might be
[Music]